I sort of fell in love with the country
with the people with the with the idea
of the revival of a Jewish community in
the country of Ukraine and I decided
that this is where I want to be I want
to stay here and open a bakery my name
is Aaron Levitz I'm a baker from New
York living in it was good on Ukraine
you
I met my my wife when I was in culinary
school in New York countries from
Ukraine so we decided to move to Ukraine
I can't really sit in New York where
everything is Jewishly comfortable when
I know that in Ukraine things are
difficult I feel that I have a larger
connection with the Jews of Ukraine
Jewish life in newsreel before the work
compared to today is a huge contrast
before the war he had many synagogues
many rabbis the Nazis came and they
shipped everyone out to Auschwitz and
now there's no real community my part
now in the Jewish community is to make
an attempt at a Jewish revival so we're
starting with food that's not really
practical to make kosher bakery in
Ukraine or knows you're not just for
Jews you're not really gonna make any
money because it's not enough juice so
that's why I want to introduce new ideas
new American pastries Jewish pastries
that are just not common here so try to
get the interests of people
I would say that I'm introducing some
Jewish and American foods that are non
judgmental some people are scared to go
to a synagogue or scared to go to a
prayer service or something but they'll
come in to a bakery and have something
tasty to eat
the
you